advice from chip Hopkins on the
entrepreneurial mindset I've seen in zoo
go triple zero you have to have the kind
of personality where you're resilient
and you can get up and keep moving I
have a number of famous quotes and one
of them is if you get knocked down get
back up again I don't really feel like I
want to let anything ultimately defeat
me you know you're going to have
failures there's no way to avoid it
especially if you're an entrepreneur if
you're doing something new of course
they're going to be mistakes how can you
not make mistakes you don't know where
you're going it's uncharted territory if
you don't have a lot of passion for it
you're not going to make it and that's I
think the big test one quality of
entrepreneurship is just persistence not
giving up because you have roadblocks
and not giving in because other people
tell you that you're nuts you are nuts
and you should be proud of it stick with
what you believe in to learn more check
out zoo go triple zero in the link below